Carrie Underwood is officially
outnumbered at home Mike and Isaiah and
I are absolutely over the moon and
excited to be adding another little fish
to our pond the cry pretty singer
welcomed another baby boy with husband
Mike Fisher he's really excited he would
have been excited for a girl too
obviously how scary doing I know you got
a baby on the way she's prepping for a
tour eventually there's a lot going on
in your life how's she feeling yeah
she's doing great actually she's
we got CMAs coming up next week which
will be a lot of fun I'm not asking you
whether you're having a boy or a girl
but what are you rooting for no yeah
we're kind of keeping owling under wraps
for now Carrie spilled on the sex of
baby number two at the 2018 CMA Awards
alongside co-host Brad Paisley Waylon or
Willie wait no come on come on
oh my gosh Willie it's a Willie what
makes it special is Brad accidentally
revealed what Keri was having on the
same stage in 2014 but it was Carrie's
fashion that sent fans into a frenzy
many speculated that the country crooner
might have a girl this time around as
she wore pops of pink leading up to the
gender-reveal this this is just been a
dream come true with album and with baby
news and all that stuff for her
pregnancy announcement she sported a
pink bomber jacket surrounded by
matching decor and kept fans on their
toes rocking subtle hints of the color
in her social media selfies I love the
color
not to mention Carrie was pretty in pink
for several appearances it's a girl you
think it is but you did say it's a whole
new ball game which indicates it could
be a boy it's either a girl or a boy
but Kari did shimmer in royal blue at
the CMT artists of the year of it when
she opened up to et about the challenges
that came with her second pregnancy it's
definitely different than the first time
and when they say every pregnancy is
different it really is just different
symptoms and I feel like I'm not like I
feel like this one's just a little
harder on my body for some reason but
it's it's really good someone who might
not be on board with some of the
family's new responsibilities
the couple's eldest son Isaiah he says
he won't change any poopy diapers though
he doesn't yeah I understand
maybe I can change his names we have a
feeling Kari won't be changing her mind
on making this happen in the future we
plan on having a girl I don't know if
you can do that but at some point we'd
really like that
[Music]